our test driver Christoph Bauer has
chosen a real revolutionary to race
around the curvy roads of Tuscany a Golf
GTI the standard golf didn't send race
car drivers hearts ablaze but the three
letters GT I changed all that they
revolutionized the compact car market
for Volkswagen for Germany and for the
world that's not feeling that Christoph
says the Gulf became the successor to
the beetle in 1974 the time of the oil
crisis when driving was banned on some
Sundays in Germany VW was convinced that
70 horsepower was enough for a golf the
Scirocco was the sporty-er line in the
VW flee back in 74 with its more
aerodynamic form it promised maximum
speeds of 175 kilometers an hour the
gulf by contrast was intended to appeal
the VW's traditional customer base
thrifty down-to-earth drivers without a
sporty bone in their body and no
particular penchant for the passing lane
how about in tightly crystal says some
engineers started tinkering with the
Gulf and their spare time he started to
develop a prototype more or less on
their own two years down the road after
a few successful test drives the
sporting version of the Gulf was
officially commissioned nowadays every
child knows the abbreviation GTI King
Jesus cuts a game to a GTI stands for
drawn Therese mo injection a synonym for
motorsport the first version was the
most popular one with sales of 460 1,000
vehicles over seven years
well this stuff says it's still pretty
nippy today thanks to its 110 horsepower
engine and a weight of just eight
hundred sixty kilos the chancy is a good
compromise between sportiness on the one
hand comfort and safety on the other VW
places a lot of importance on safety
this sticker ask drivers to remain built
it in until the motor has come to a
complete standstill so filling Steve's
danke cometh to see cost was also an
important factor the development of the
first GTI costs just seven million West
German marks the 1.6 litre engine was
originally built for the audi 80 GTE
back then the Audi plant in Ingo Scott
was responsible for developing all of
the company's engines bayswater stuff
says the DW then focused on breaking
through the 180 kilometer an hour
barrier that proved tricky at first
probably because of the air drag but
they came up with a simple and practical
solution the front spoiler as a result
they could proudly announce top speeds
of 100 83 km/h spit singer's winnicott
honda try oxy haha but this front
spoiler which made such a splash in the
mid-70s isn't the GTI's only trademark
the woody I McChrystal says little
details have earned the car a big
following like the oil temperature gauge
and the plaid pattern on the sport seats
like in the Scirocco the iconic gold
ball gearshift warms the hearts of fans
that's the spa key to knowledge the
father I'm not really on the outside to
VW had to show that the GTI was no
ordinary golf so Christophe says the
front spoiler red bordered radiator
grille and the black trim were features
of the GTI until the mid 80s and of
course the wing extensions 100 75
millimeter tires came as standard but
the GTI had room for once as white as
200 5 millimeters like the Porsches of
the time well that's what I must pass
any war so if it's empty much bucket
can't even find out who was afraid of
the big bad both the competition that su
in 1976 the car costs less than 14,000
Deutsche marks and can go from zero to
100 kilometers an hour and nine seconds
but for many owners that wasn't enough
they pimped their GTI's for all they
were worth
they love to turn the GTI's 1.6 litre
engine with its Bosch mechanical fuel
injection as pathology stuff says it was
very popular especially in small towns
to soup up the GTI with spoilers wide
tires sports suspensions and seats and
big bass speakers after parading in
front of a loco disco the car would
occasionally wind up in a ditch so
original 4 Series GT eyes are real
rarities the sheet metal used to make
the cars was it always top quality which
has also led to the demise of many GT is
Christophe says as of the mid 70 sporty
cars were rolling off the volkswagen
assembly lines in Wolfsburg as well as
at Porsche and Ferrari the GTI started a
trend toward sport sedans so the GTI
definitely deserves to be called a
milestone an automobile history
definitely fatigued with its compact
form front-wheel drive an impressive
performance the GTI didn't just prove a
winning recipe for VW the first GTI
created a whole new market segment in
the automobile industry
you